Luffy has changed. A lot. And I bet you may
not remember the time Luffy absorbed the power
of one hundred shadows. You probably also
forgot the time he went undercover inside
a marine base. And you definitely didn’t
know about the time Luffy became a literal
thunder giant all the way back in 2009. Well
in this video we’re going to explain every
single step in the evolution of Luffy on his
path to become pirate king. And in the impossible
case that you actually DO remember every single
version of Luffy in this video, you can truly
call yourself a One Piece master.
Starting with Luffy as a kid. When Luffy first
meets Shanks, he is 7 years old. Determined
to be a pirate, Luffy stabs himself in the
face, just to show Shank that's he was brave
enough to join the crew. The Red-Haired captain
says he is still too young. While Luffy is
disappointed, he has earned the respect of
Shanks’ crew. Which is great until…
Luffy eats his legendary devil fruit. For
now, an enraged Shanks tells Luffy that his
entire body has become rubber and he can longer
swim. Pretty silly, right? Well just wait
until you see how this one bite of fruit changes
Luffy’s life forever. Soon after Luffy is
saved from bandits, he gets his iconic straw
hat from Shanks and promises that he will
become a great pirate.
That promise begins by training with his adopted
brothers, Ace and Sabo. These three grow stronger
by fighting wild beasts of the jungle and
Luffy learns to control his new rubber body.
Beyond growing stronger, Ace, Sabo, and Luffy
form a bond of brotherhood that teaches Luffy
to never give up on his friends.
Now skipping forward, seventeen-year old Luffy
starts his journey. He is strong, confident,
and dreams of becoming king of the pirates.
He sets out on a small boat ready to gather
a strong crew.
Luffy’s next step is to become a real pirate
captain. In chapter 42, Luffy is given a proper
ship after saving Usopp’s hometown. Together
with his three crewmates they design their
first flag. And if you don’t know, flags
and other symbols are incredibly important
in the One Piece story. Stick around and you’ll
see why. This smiling symbol shows the world
that the Straw Hat Pirates have arrived, bringing
hope to many across the world. Luffy is truly
a captain now, but he has much to learn.
Including that pirates are not the only force
in the world. After defeating the fishman
Arlong and freeing Nami’s village, Luffy
becomes a wanted man. With a bounty of 30
million berries, the World Government has
taken notice of Luffy’s victories in the
East Blue. They decide he is now enough of
a threat that they would pay for his capture.
It goes to show that in addition to making
friends, Luffy is gaining enemies.
And the World Government almost gets their
wish right away. In Logue Town, the scene
of Gol D. Roger’s execution, Luffy is captured
and almost executed by the pirate Buggy the
Clown. But despite knives hanging over his
neck, Luffy laughs at death. He shouts to
the onlooking crowd that he is more than happy
to die in pursuit of his dreams.
Those who knew Roger are struck by the similarities
between this rubber boy and the former pirate
king.
And just like Roger, it seems that Luffy is
protected by more than his strong will and
desire. A freak storm sets him free, and now
he and his crew finally enter the Grand Line.
This is where pirates make their name and
those wishing to become pirate king are truly
tested.
Still, Luffy has much more to learn if he
wants to protect his friends and pursue his
dreams.
Speaking of dreams, do you remember we mentioned
flags are important? Well in Drum Island,
Luffy takes a full cannon blast to protect
the flag of Dr. Hiriluk. This quack doctor
is the man who raised Chopper and gave us
one of the most famous quotes in One Piece.
By protecting the flag, Luffy shows his friends
that no one will get in the way of their dreams.
And this bravery convinces Chopper to pursue
his own dream and join the crew.
But Luffy’s faith is quickly tested when
he gets impaled on the hook of the Warlord
Crocodile. While fighting against the Sand
devil fruit user, Luffy is unable to land
even a single blow. The Warlord mocks Luffy’s
dreams and throws him into the sand to die.
While Luffy survives, this is his first major
defeat by a villain and it shows us all that
he has a long way to go before he is king
of anything.
Luckily, learning is one of Luffy’s biggest
strengths. Especially, when it comes to battle.
In their next fight, Luffy uses this ridiculous
looking form where he has drunk an absurd
amount of water. You see, Luffy has learned
that because each Logia devil fruit turns
their user into an element, each of them also
has a unique natural weakness. And since Crocodile
is made of sand, getting him wet makes the
sand of his body stick together, allowing
Luffy to actually land his attacks.
And even though Luffy loses this battle, he
eventually manages to defeat Crocodile just
a short while later and saves the kingdom
of Alabasta. Now having defeated his first
Warlord, Luffy earns his second bounty. With
an increase from 30 million to 100 million
berries. This shows that the world Government
views Luffy as a growing threat and wants
him taken care of.
However, bounties are not the only measure
of strength. On the island of Jaya, Luffy,
Nami, and Zoro are mocked by the pirate Bellemy,
who spills food and drink over the straw hats.
Bellemy states that pirate dreams are foolish
and that Luffy and his crew should be afraid
of him. But this moment shows how much Luffy
has matured since we saw him as a child in
chapter one. Instead of fighting back against
pirates who are beneath him, Luffy simply
walks away, a striking similarity to Shanks
all the way back at the start of the series.
But that’s the last time Bellemy takes advantage
of Luffy and his friends. The next time Luffy
sees Bellemy, the pirate has beat up these
guys [show cricket and his crew] and Luffy
is out for revenge. Despite Bellemy springing
around with the power of his devil fruit,
Luffy delivers one of the most iconic punches
in the series, taking out Bellemy with a single
hit. This shows Bellemy not to underestimate
the power of dreams or make judgements based
only on bounty.
Also on Jaya, Luffy’s rising bounty has
drawn the attention of Blackbeard. These two
pirates will be connected throughout the entire
story. Eiichiro Oda, the author of One Piece,
introduces Blackbeard as Luffy’s physical
and philosophical opposite. Luffy is small.
Blackbeard is large. Luffy is honest. Blackbeard
is deceptive. Luffy loves cherry pie. Blackbeard
hates it. They are the light and the dark.
However, they both believe in the power of
dreams.
Later, the Straw Hats escape from Blackbeard’s
attempt to capture them. And while Luffy thinks
Blackbeard is strange, he cannot imagine the
pain this man will cause him and the hate
he will later feel towards Blackbeard.
Now the only thing we love more about Luffy
than his growing strength and fame are the
countless times he makes his friends or the
viewers laugh. In fact, there are so many
instances of Luffy acting comically stupid
that it would probably deserve a video of
its own. But I still want to focus on a few
examples here. Just on Skypiea for instance,
Luffy makes fun of both Zoro and Sanji as
they head towards a deadly trial. He hilariously
turns his brain off in order to fight Enel.
And he throws a massive party with the wild
animals of the forest.
And by the way, it is this exact scene right
here [bonfire scene] that Oda has stated is
one of his top three favorite scenes he has
ever drawn. The bonfire scene hints at Luffy’s
most dangerous ability. At anytime, anywhere
in the world, this man can make friends. Partying,
laughing, and having fun, he gives hope to
those in need and freedom to those who are
slaves. Turns out, this is our first major
piece of foreshadowing for Luffy’s true
power at the end of this video.
Speaking of liberation, Skypiea is also the
first time Luffy fights a so-called god of
the One Piece world. In this arc, the Lighting
fruit user Enel has enslaved the citizens
of Skypiea. He is about to destroy the land
and people before traveling to the moon. But
with a ball of gold stuck on his arm, Luffy
defeats Enel, ringing the legendary bell of
Shandora. The ringing of the bell travels
far down to the sea, giving Luffy’s friends
hope and reminding them to never give up on
their dreams.
And one dream we only got to see in the anime
is Luffy’s time as a marine. In the G8 filler
episodes, Luffy and the crew are stuck in
a marine facility. But even disguised as a
marine, Luffy can’t resist stealing food
right off the Vice-Admiral’s plate. And
this is the closest he gets to fulfilling
his grandfather’s dream of Luffy becoming
a marine. But if you’ve ever wondered what
Luffy’s life would have really been like
if he chose to be a marine instead of a pirate,
you can click this video right here.
And one other thing I bet you never expected
to see in One Piece is Afro Luffy. I mean
come on. Who wouldn’t want this marvelous
head of hair in their lives? We can all offer
our thanks to god Usopp for giving Luffy this
incredible makeover.
But while they’re still joking around here,
these two best friends actually face a major
conflict in Water 7 just a short while later.
And it’s here we see Luffy’s first major
test as captain. With their ship unable to
sail further, Luffy decides to buy a new one
to be able to continue their journey. Usopp
is outraged. He doesn’t want to abandon
this ship for 2 reasons. Number 1, they had
received it as a thank you for saving Usopp’s
village. But number 2, Usopp had been the
one to repair the ship throughout their adventures.
Up until this point, Usopp has been feeling
more and more useless compared to everyone
else in the crew, and repairing their ship
was his justification for being part of Luffy’s
crew. So when Luffy makes this choice, Usopp
fears he will be left behind as well and rejects
his decision by challenging Luffy to a duel.
As you can imagine, this does not go well
for Usopp. Through bitter tears, the crew
watches Luffy assert himself as captain and
Usopp is defeated. And he then leaves the
crew for a time.
Now while hard to watch, this marks an important
development for the Straw Hat captain. As
Zoro comments, if the crew can’t believe
in their captain’s decisions, the crew will
fall apart. In this case, Luffy shows us that
he is growing as a leader. And even though
it is difficult to watch his best friend suffer,
he can make tough decisions for the wellbeing
of the crew.
But at the same time he’s still our loveable
idiot Luffy, somehow managing getting stuck
between two buildings.
And it’s here that Luffy faces his biggest
challenge yet. With Robin kidnapped and the
crew unable to defeat these secret government
agents, Luffy comes up with a new technique:
Gear 2nd.
With this power up, Luffy uses his rubber
body to pump oxygen to his muscles faster
than humanly possible. This gives him a huge
boost in speed and power, allowing him to
finally defeat one of the secret agents. However,
this power up is not without risks, because
this technique will likely shorten Luffy’s
lifespan.
But as Luffy learned from Ace and Sabo, nothing
else matters when you need to protect your
friends.
Immediately after, the crew stares across
the gap between themselves and the world government
agents. Robin is still captured and tells
the crew to leave her behind. But Luffy sees
the burden the World Government has put upon
Robin and he orders Usopp to shoot down the
government’s flag, basically a declaration
of war. As the flag burns, this act tells
Robin that the crew will do anything or will
fight anyone to protect their friends. Luffy
begs Robin to tell them what she really wants,
and in response she screams: “I want to
live”.
For all of Luffy’s steps so far, this one
is most significant. There is no going back
from challenging the World Government, and
now the rulers of the world have their eyes
on him.
And just like any other challenge, Luffy rises
to face it. Or in this case, literally grows.
When fighting the government’s most dangerous
secret agent, Luffy reveals another new form:
Gear 3rd.
To achieve this form, Luffy blows air straight
into his rubber bones, making any part of
his body supersized. Leading to this [end
of ch 421], this [end of ch 510], this [ch
547 luffy giant stamp], and…
…this? *confused tone* [show chibi luffy]
Remember when we said Luffy’s power ups
have down sides? Well, after Luffy first uses
Gear 3, it temporarily turns him into this
chibi Luffy. Eventually, Luffy grows strong
enough to not have this side effect, but for
a time it is quite hilarious.
Now after rescuing Robin and escaping from
the World Government, it is time for Luffy’s
3rd Bounty. 300 million berries. Three times
his last bounty. Truly, Luffy has arrived
and has proven himself a force to be taken
seriously in the Grand Line.
And Luffy’s grown so much, he doesn’t
even need to fight zombies, he just pushes
them back into the ground.
Now, that was a lot of story progression for
Luffy. Next let’s take a quick look at some
of the most unique forms Luffy has taken in
the story, as well as the incredible loyalty
and spirit of his crew.
First is Oar’s Luffy. When Luffy’s shadow
is stolen by Warlord Gecko Moria, it is placed
into the frozen body of the demon giant Oars.
Based on Moria’s devil fruit powers, the
revived Oars should be under his control,
but Luffy’s strong will sends Oars on a
rampaging search for meat. Classic Luffy.
But eventually, Oars must follow Moria’s
orders and the straw hat crew is unable to
stop the giant demon. That is, until we get
this [show nightmare luffy]. By absorbing
the power of one hundred shadows, Luffy transforms
into this dark, super form with the power
to easily stop Oars’ massive punch. While
this form only lasts for a short time, Luffy’s
ability to command the shadows of so many
individuals demonstrates the strength of his
spirit.
But what’s more impressive is the sheer
damage that Luffy takes in order to protect
his friends. In one of the most creative visuals
of damage I have ever seen in any series,
Luffy literally becomes pain.
After defeating Moria, the Warlord Kuma arrives
and wipes out the exhausted straw hat crew.
Kuma’s purpose is to eliminate Luffy for
the World Government. But both Zoro and Sanji
demand to take Luffy’s place. Kuma is so
impressed by their loyalty to their captain
that instead of killing Luffy, Kuma uses his
Paw fruit powers to repel all the pain Luffy
has taken. He gives it to Zoro, resulting
in one of the most iconic scenes in one piece.
Nothing happened.
Except that Zoro almost dies.
However, this sacrifice shows just how much
the crew cares for their captain. And Kuma
departs full of respect for the straw hat
crew.
Which is a huge contrast to the respect this
space-suit wearing world noble deserves. The
celestial dragons are the rulers of the world
government and self-proclaimed gods. When
he decides to purchase Luffy’s friend as
a slave, Luffy punches him so hard, it sends
shockwaves around the world.
Marines quickly arrive to rescue the world
noble. And Luffy welcomes the challenge. But
what he doesn’t know is just how unprepared
he is for what is to come.
With the marines and cyborg Pacifistas sent
to capture them, the straw hats struggle to
stay alive. They are still wounded from their
fight with Moria, and are soundly defeated.
They only survive death because of Kuma, who
instead of killing them scatters each of the
crew to the far corners of the world.
Alone, wounded, and full of doubts, Luffy
is at his lowest point. Or so he thinks.
Now one step in Luffy’s evolution you may
not be familiar with is Thor Luffy. That’s
right. The god of thunder himself. No not
that one [show gear 5 quickly]. This one.
In the movie Strong World, Luffy battles Roger’s
former rival Shiki. Fighting under a storm
cloud, Luffy launches his foot into the storm
and brings down an electric strike on Shiki’s
head, defeating the former rival of Roger.
Alongside Luffy’s resistance to lightning,
another recurring plot point is Luffy’s
ability to survive poison. We see this emphasized
in the underwater government prison, Impel
Down, where Luffy is attempting to rescue
his captured brother Ace. When Luffy fights
against the warden of the jail, he is covered
with so much poison a normal man would have
died instantly. But Luffy survives due to
his new friends and his tremendous will to
live.
Now, while Luffy can be quite dumb at times,
we’ve already seen that his battle intelligence
is outstanding. During the prison escape,
Luffy protects his fellow escapees by wearing
wax armor to keep back the poisonous warden.
This protection allows them enough time to
escape Impel Down, which was previously said
to be impossible. Another insult to the world
government.
However, the world government and the marines
would quickly have their revenge.
You see, Luffy rushes to save his brother,
who set to be publicly executed in Marineford,
the main base of the marines. While Luffy
is outmatched by the upper class fighters
of the marines, his determination to save
his brother earns him the respect many strong
pirates. Including the Emperor of the Sea
Whitebeard, who is also trying to rescue Ace.
But even their combined assault doesn’t
stop the marines from beginning the execution.
And it is now that Luffy fully announces himself
as a candidate to be the pirate king.
As the blades come down on Ace’s neck, Luffy
unleashes his most dominant power. Conquerors
Haki - The will of the Supreme King. This
burst of willpower knocks out weak individuals
and gives Luffy time to rescue his brother.
As the stunned marines and pirates look on,
the marine admiral Akainu decides Luffy is
just as much a threat as Ace and vows to kill
them both.
Luffy succeeds in freeing Ace, and the brothers
escape…
Almost.
With Luffy powerless to stop Admiral Akainu,
Ace sacrifices himself so that Luffy can live.
*short pause* Ace dies. *short pause* And
Luffy’s will crumbles. He is unable to process
the loss of his beloved brother.
It is a painful reminder that for all the
progress Luffy has made, he is still far away
from being able to protect his friends from
the strongest fighters in the seas.
Grief almost breaks Luffy, and only thinking
about the love of his crew helps him recover.
He is their captain, and if he is going to
protect them, Luffy must continue to grow
stronger. So Luffy decides they all need to
train. And the straw hats disappear from the
world of pirates.
For two years, Luffy trains with Rayleigh,
learning the basics of Haki that will allow
him to fight the monsters that await. This
is an opportunity to learn from a master,
but Luffy far surpasses Rayleigh’s expectations.
It takes Luffy only 18 months to learn the
basics of haki, and then Rayleigh leaves so
Luffy can further develop on his own.
Two years later the world has changed. Including
our favorite captain. In fact, he looks like
this? [Fake Luffy] No wait…this? [How Boa
sees Luffy] No. Okay, this? [Mustache Luffy].
Alright, seriously though.
Luffy returns to Sabaody where his crew is
waiting. He is stronger, full of confidence,
and ready to continue his journey. But the
marines are also waiting. Faced by the same
enemies from two years ago, Luffy shows exactly
why he has earned his new400 million berry
bounty by easily defeating the cyborg Pacifictas
that nearly killed his crew 2 years ago.
It is a giant leap forward. And speaking of
giants, Luffy becomes one in his anime fight
with former marine Shuzo. While this time
he needed size-shifting Lily’s assistance
to become giant, it won’t be the last time
we see a giant straw hat captain before the
end of this video.
Luffy continues to show off his new powers
in Fishman island. Surrounded by 100 thousand
enemy fishmen, Luffy knocks out 50 thousand
of them with a single burst on Conqueror’s
Haki. He is one of only a few characters in
the entire series who have this unique haki
ability.
Another new power is the special move, Red
Hawk. When fighting the fishman villain Hody
Jones, Luffy ignites his arm, finishing the
fight with a fiery punch, which he created
in memory of his fallen brother Fire-fist
Ace. Most importantly it’s a sign that he
has finally made peace with his brother’s
death. While it doesn’t make any sense why
a rubber person should be able to conjure
up fire powers, it all makes sense when Luffy’s
true abilities are revealed hundreds of chapters
later.
And speaking of power ups, Luffy’s ultimate
transformation is this: Centaur Luffy [Luffy
with Kinemon’s legs from Punk Hazard. No
other explanation needed.
And now that Luffy has announced himself back
on the stage, he enters the realm of pirate
politics for the first time. On Punk Hazard,
Luffy and the warlord Trafalgar Law, form
an alliance to take down Emperor of the Sea,
Kaido: the strongest creature alive. This
marks another super important step for Luffy.
Even though Robin warns that pirate alliances
end in betrayal, Luffy chooses to trust Law
as they both seek to rise to the top of the
pirate world.
But at their current power levels, neither
would have even the slightest chance against
Kaido yet. However, this alliance shows one
of Luffy’s greatest strengths as a captain.
He knows he can’t achieve his dreams all
on his own. If it weren’t for his friends
he would get lost, starve, or die of some
random poison. But instead of being prideful,
he offers and accepts help for everyone’s
benefit. That’s something we should all
learn from Luffy.
Something we shouldn’t learn from Luffy
on the other hand is disguises. Here he gains
quite the following fighting in the Dressrosa
Colosseum dressed as the old man Lucy.
It is also in Dressrosa that we get our next
step in Luffy’s Gears. With Doflamingo turning
the world into string around the straw hats,
a desperate Luffy unveils Gear 4. This bouncing
ball of rubber and haki is the result of Luffy’s
training for two years.
While this form grants Luffy superior speed
and power, the initial downside is that he
quickly loses his energy. When he runs out,
Gear 4 deflates and Luffy is unable to use
Haki for ten minutes. When Doflamingo survives
Luffy’s first round of Gear 4, Luffy must
rely on his friends to delay the puppet master.
Which they do, barely. But it is enough for
Luffy to return and punch Doflamingo straight
through the ground.
This is another warlord defeated by Luffy.
Now the path to become an Emperor begins.
So it is fitting that Luffy - along with earning
a new bounty of 500 million berries - also
gains a larger following at the end of Dressrosa.
Many of the fighters who took down the Doflamingo
family pledge their allegiance to Luffy. This
forms the Straw Hat Grand Fleet, a strong
group of pirate captains who will come to
Luffy’s aid when called upon.
And the party doesn’t stop there.
On this giant walking elephant, Luffy makes
an alliance with the animal mink tribe of
Zou and the samurai of Wano to take down Kaido.
In addition, they learn they must collect
the Road Poneglyphs in order to find Laugh
Tale, the island where the One Piece treasure
can be found.
This is a huge moment for Luffy. Remember
he only started with a small boat and a dream.
Now he has a badass crew, tons of allies,
and he has a clear picture of how to find
the One Piece. Truly he has come a long way.
But there’s still much further to go.
Now, when training with Rayleigh during the
time skip, Luffy was told that Haki blooms
most during battle. We see this when Luffy
goes to the territory of Big Mom, another
Emperor of the Sea. When fighting one of Big
Mom’s commanders, Luffy uses Tank Man, a
buffed up, sumo version of Gear 4. This form
allows him to defeat the commander and start
his march towards rescuing Sanji from Big
Mom.
To do this, Luffy makes another agreement
with a pirate, Capone Gang Bege. In this meeting,
the two captains plot a way to take down Big
Mom. AND we get the most dapped up version
of Luffy to date. [show cartoon version].
No this one. [show suited up Luffy ch 858].
Pretty clean in my opinion.
While we don’t get a full flight between
Big Mom and Luffy yet, Luffy fights for hours
with Big Mom’s strongest son, Charlotte
Katakuri. It is during this fight that Luffy
learns his first form of advanced Haki: Future
Sight. When fully concentrating, both Luffy
and Katakuri can see moments into the future.
As their fight drags on, Luffy also unveils
Snake Man. This form emphasizes speed. Along
with future sight, it is a frightening combination
for opponents and another step forward for
Luffy.
After defeating Katakuri, Luffy and the crew
escape Big Mom’s territory intact and with
a copy of Big Mom’s Road poneglyph. This
incredible feat has only previously been accomplished
by former Pirate King Roger. This also marks
the moment that much of the world views Luffy
as an Emperor of the Sea. He gets a massive
bounty increase to 1.5 billion berries and
for the first time he has survived a conflict
with an Emperor's crew.
However, according the Shanks, Luffy still
isn’t ready to fulfill their promise of
becoming a great pirate. Quite the demanding
mentor.
Luffy finally reaches those heights in Wano,
land of the samurai. Filled with the spirit
of bushido, Luffy grabs his own sword, but
clearly doesn’t know how to use it. And
Zoro is horrified to see Luffy *punching*
with the sword. Someone please take Luffy’s
sword away before he hurts himself.
And it is in Wano that we get our first full
out fight with an Emperor of the Sea. After
Luffy believes Kaido killed his crew, Luffy
attacks the azure dragon, raining punches
on the drunken Emperor. But he doesn’t even
leave a scratch. When Kaido fights seriously,
Luffy is taken out in one hit, leading to
his imprisonment and training arc for Prisoner
Luffy.
And just like Luffy learned advanced observation
Haki fighting Katakuri, in the Wano prison
Luffy learns about advanced armament Haki
- also known as Ryo. This technique allows
Luffy to extend his haki coating into another
object, destroying it from the inside. With
weeks of practice, he masters Ryo and believes
he now has what it takes to fight toe to toe
with Kaido.
This leads us to the raid on Kaido’s castle,
where on the top of the skull dome Luffy confronts
the newly allied Kaido AND Big Mom. Here we
see our fully fledged captain squaring off
with confidence against the strongest fighters
in the one piece world. He is now truly fighting
the gods of the pirate world.
And Luffy starts the battle walking calmly
between them to help his fallen friend.
Wow. What balls Luffy has.
But it is an important moment in Luffy’s
journey. These two Emperors, Big Mom and Kaido,
have ruled the seas for decades. They would
kill Luffy’s friends in an instant. But
no longer does Luffy need to run away to protect
his friends. He can fight them, beat them,
and move past them to achieve the dreams they
never could.
In a flash of violent flame, Luffy unleashes
the special technique Red Roc. A gigantic
version of the Red Hawk flame that symbolizes
his brother. Luffy smashes Kaido into the
ground, making the Emperor bleed for the first
time against Luffy.
But the rest of the battle does not go so
easily. Kaido is faster, stronger, and has
more experience than Luffy. And Luffy’s
Ryo is not enough to seriously damage Kaido.
The Straw Hat captain loses again and is cast
off into the sea to die. But the battle was
not a waste.
By fighting Kaido, Luffy learns another form
of Haki. Advanced Conquerors. Similar to Ryo,
this allows Luffy to channel his unmatched
conqueror’s spirit into fists and feet.
Luffy climbs back up to the top of the skull
dome and confronts Kaido once more.
And this is where things get silly.
Even with all of Luffy’s progress, all of
his Gears and advanced Haki, Kaido is still
one step above. That is until Gear 5. Or,
as we learn, the true form of Luffy’s devil
fruit, the Sun God Nika.
And this, let me tell you, was a twist that
no one saw coming. In this form, Luffy turns
completely white and cannot stop laughing.
He becomes a true representation of freedom,
allowing Luffy to fully unleash the most incredible
power in the world: his imagination. Nicknamed
Toon Force by One Piece fans, Luffy turns
the fight into a cartoon. He catches and throws
lightning, punches straight through the Emperor,
and even turns dragon Kaido into a jump rope.
The fight has become insanity. The warrior
of liberation has awoken.
However, as with all of Luffy’s Gears, there
is a down side. We see during the fight that
Luffy’s life span is dwindling. He repeatedly
turns into this wrinkly old man and seems
exhausted by his wild transformation.
But even the loss of life span doesn’t stop
our captain. In one last attack, Luffy rises
into the clouds. Kaido hovers below him as
a flaming, destructive force of nature. The
situation seems hopeless, but as with many
of Luffy’s fights, the answer is to simply
punch harder. And that’s what Luffy does.
He comes out of the clouds with an enormous
fist. And he smashes Kaido all the way through
Wano and into the volcanic lava below the
island.
With Big Mom defeated by other members of
the alliance, the Straw Hats are victorious,
and days later Luffy is officially named an
Emperor of the Sea, with a new bounty of 3
billion berries to back it up.
And who knows what crazy new forms we will
see Luffy take before he finally finds the
One Piece. However, as I explain in this video
right here, there is a really good chance
that Luffy’s final bounty at the end of
the story will not only surpass that of the
former Pirate King, but even exceed the crazy
amount of 10 Billion berries. If you want
to find out more, make sure to watch that
video, right here. Shanks for watching.